maintenant qu'on connaît davantage les
résultats l'impression que le pire n'est
pas arrivé et côté d'une satisfaction
avant toute chose car encore une fois
les rôles et m'ont apporté leur
confiance près de 53% pour ce premier
tour cela montre encore une fois tout ce
que nous mettons en place depuis ces
années et puis à chaque nouveau lectorat
c'est les mêmes habitants m'ont font
pleinement confiance alors maintenant
aujourd'hui effectivement dans le cas de
ce canton que l'on belle et je pense que
les résultats de ce premier tour sont
plus qu'encourageants dans une commune
qui votent à près de 70% à gauche donc
cela montre bien aussi car avec le maire
d'hérouville que je suis a pas laissé
indifférent la candidature que je suis
et cela me rend d'autant plus fiers donc
il nous restera encore quelques tours
devant nous donc toute la semaine pour
pouvoir afficher notre volonté et
apporter des explications du sens à mon
engagement politique pour les deux
communes à l'échelle plus large du
calvados
le front national sera très présent au
second tour oui le front national
on le dit depuis un certain nombre de
semaines ça se concrétise
malheureusement ce soir mais
encore une fois je pense que le
gouvernement actuel à sa pleine et
entière responsabilité
du résultat du front national ce soir
donc c'est au gouvernement du parti
socialiste d'en tirer les conséquences
on le sentait bien depuis un certain
nombre de mois ou d'années et
malheureusement nous sommes confrontés à
une situation
qui aura besoin justement d'un d'arguin
d'un sursaut républicain c'est ce que je
souhaite particulièrement car mes
engagements que ce soit un gros bide
hérouville soirée en ville c'est près de
10% du front national pour moi c'est un
peu trop il reste encore une fois
beaucoup beaucoup à faire pour apporter
il a affiché encore une fois des
convictions que je voudrais faire
partager à toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont voté front national ce soir et
dans l'hypothèse d'un duel gauche droite
pendant front national dans d'autres
cantons vous pensez qu'ils ont un
sursaut qui va s'exprimer il faut
l'espérer faut l'espérer à condition que
l'on n'en voit pas des messages que ce
soit au niveau du national ou bien local
je pense qu'on a nos valeurs nos valeurs
républicaines à nous de l'affiché faire
du porte-à-porte aller vers les gens une
élection comme celle ci a le elle ne se
traduit pas sûr uniquement à coups de
prospectus c'est aller à la rencontre
des gens et puis surtout comprendre et
analyser le ras-le-bol d'une bonne
partie de la population française oui